professor David Simon at the City
University of New York's Brooklyn
College was ordered to make some changes
to a syllabus because it supposedly
constituted sexual harassment and
according to Simon a university
administrator expressed that there were
three problems with the syllabus number
one being that under the grading portion
of the syllabus the ten percent grade
for effort quote applied only to select
students when appropriate suggested
sexual harassment now how is the sexual
harassment it's not totally clear Simon
was interviewed by reason.com and said
that his department chair said that the
ten percent section could be construed
as a prelude to sexual harassment
because it might imply that in certain
cases to certain students may be sexual
favors would be allowed in order to
improve a grade under that ten percent
effort based on when it is required for
certain students now side iment old
reason.com uh that he was told it should
be changed at once he was also initially
in trouble for writing in his syllabus
this classroom is a quote unsafe space
for those uncomfortable with viewpoints
with which they may disagree all
constituents constitutionally protected
speech is welcome uh the director of the
department ultimately conceded that that
was fine so this is sort of odd right
the matter is now officially closed to
some this will be read sort of as no
harm no foul Simon's ten your job was
never on the line it was ultimately
closed that's it others say oh no no no
this is really making that line very
hazy between academic freedom and campus
interpretations of title nine now I have
broader thoughts I've always thought
that effort grades are really sort of
subjective and actually a really good
way for a professor to if they want to
knock off a full letter grade for a
student who maybe expresses an unpopular
opinion in class or something like that
and I've talked to my mom about this
because she's a college professor has
been for a very long time she said
instead of effort which she puts on the
syllabus is
attendance and participation in class
are uh more objective measures to try to
avoid this idea of all it's totally
subjective who says what effort is you
can measure attendance and you can also
measure participation in class the thing
that really strikes me as odd here is
that a geology professor is putting in
his syllabus things about politically
correct culture and safe spaces at all I
mean I get it in humanities I get it in
social sciences okay but geology safe
space warning or there won't be safe
spaces allowed here and blah blah blah
political correctness in a geology class
it strikes me as a little bit odd and
add you know the bigger picture of this
of and in terms of well no harm no foul
because the investigation was closed or
no this was really an attempt to try to
stifle free speech I don't even get why
you would need something like this in a
geology class did you ever have set hard
science classes Pat where things became
political or issues of safe spaces or or
political correctness even came up I
didn't mean there was environmental
science classes which were inherently
political cuz you know the policies
behind them yet this I never experienced
this either when I was I mean I believe
me I was in many very political classes
within social sciences with in
humanities etcetera none of the
admittedly relatively few science
classes I took astronomy for example uh
various intro science classes when I was
an undergrad there was nothing even
bordering on anything requiring a safe
space declaration one way or the other
or anything like that I find that a
little weird and that's what a lot of
people emailing me reacting to which is
yeah effort whether you think effort is
a legitimate part of a great or not that
sort of one conversation but a geology
class even requiring this that suggests
to some people in our audience that
something was already up with this
professor I don't know I don't know the
guy beyond the story and maybe we'll
learn more about it send me your
thoughts on this Omaha Steaks sent me a
great package of steaks and it was
fantastic as some of the audience knows
my girlfriend is pescetarian so I
invited over some of my meat-eating
friends
and we use my new grill that i finally
got now that it's almost fall and
everybody loved it it was terrific I
kind of rather grill in the fall than
summer just less oppressively hot and
the limited time family grill pack that
Omaha Steaks is offering for just forty
nine ninety nine is a really great way
to do it you will get to filet mignons
to top sirloins for boneless pork chops
for chicken fried steaks a 12 ounce
package of all beef meatballs for omaha
steaks burgers for gourmet jumbo francs
a 16 ounce package of Omaha steak house
fries for caramel apple tartlets Omaha
Steaks seasoning and for additional
omaha steaks burgers and just for my
listeners omaha steaks is offering all
of this for only 49 99 this is a huge
savings go to Omaha Steaks dot-com enter
my code Pakman in the search bar and add
the family grill pack to your cart do
not miss this deal visit Omaha Steaks
dot-com and enter my code Pakman in the
search bar to get over 30 gourmet items
for 4999